des chercheurs morel et en intelligence
artificielle se mobilisent pour aider à
mettre au point des outils informatiques
pour contrer la pandémie du coronavirus
pour nous en parler le professeur yoshua
bengio pionnier dans le développement de
l'apprentissage profond alors bonsoir
monsieur bendjo bonsoir alors
l'intelligence artificielle pourrait
venir à notre rescousse finalement pour
contrer cette crise du coronavirus c'est
une des sciences effectivement en fait
presque tous les chercheurs dans le
monde en plein discipline aujourd'hui
sont pris d'une frénésie pour voir ce
qu'il peut faire pour contribuer à
lutter contre ce monstre qui nous
attaque
alors vous parlez d'une application
mobile pour essayer d'améliorer le
dépistage alors vous vous en parler oui
alors aujourd'hui on fait le dépistage
surtout à la main de quoi il s'agit
c'est que quand quelqu'un a eu un test
positif
on voudrait contacter les personnes
qu'il a rencontrées avec qui il a passé
du temps pour les avertir qu'il ya un
risque qu'ils soient eux-mêmes affectés
par la maladie
mais ce processus là est très imparfait
alors la technologie peut nous aider
avec les téléphones on peut identifier
les rencontres qu'on a fait le temps
qu'on a passé avec différentes personnes
de manière beaucoup plus fiable et
ensuite on peut utiliser ça pour donner
du feedback aux gens pour faire en sorte
que les gens qui sont les plus à risques
fasse plus attention est aujourd'hui un
des enjeux importants pour sortir de la
crise c'est d'une part comment baisser
la vitesse de propagation du virus et
donc qui se fait à travers les fameux
contact mais aussi permettre à ceux qui
sont pas infectés d'avoir une activité
qui s'approche de plusieurs dans le
futur de plus en plus de villes vie
normale pour pouvoir travailler donc ce
compromis entre réussir à sortir et
empêcher qu'ils aient plus de
l'infection on peut l'améliorer avec des
outils qui identifie les gens qui sont
plus à risque alors comment vous allez
parvenir à cette impasse que vous avez
besoin de des données individuelles de
personnes oui alors pour que ça
fonctionne
il va falloir que les gens installent
sur leur téléphone une application qu'on
est en train de développer on n'est pas
les seuls enfin ça se passe partout dans
le monde et à ce moment là
quand les gens qui ont leur téléphone en
poche se promène sa va enregistrer les
le fait que vous étiez à peu près au
même endroit à peu près bon moment avec
tel autre personne mais de manière
anonyme de manière qui préserve la vie
privée qui va faire qu'ensuite on va
pouvoir retracer cette chaîne de contact
et d'identifier les gens qui sont les
plus à risque et donc l'objectif final
l'objectif final c'est de changer les
comportements des gens pour qu'ils aient
plus conscience du risque qui pose pour
les gens qu'ils aiment mais aussi pour
la société
les aider à se connecter mieux avec
l'information qui existe aujourd'hui de
la santé publique pour leur donner les
bonnes recommandations en fonction de
housses situe dans la progression de la
maladie où ils sont en bonne santé
datant mieux est finalement arrivé à
contrôler l'expansion de la maladie nous
permettre de de sortir plus vite dans
quelques semaines dans quelques mois de
cette période de confinement alors
justement vous avez dit que d'autres
pays l'ont fait vous fiez entre autres
sur l'exemple du singapour de singapour
oui alors enfin en chine
ils ont utilisé le traçage à la main
mais à singapour ils ont construit une
application qui utilisent les téléphones
pour identifier le fait que deux
personnes sont à proximité et garder
trace de ces informations
on essaie de faire quelque chose de
semblable mais qui met beaucoup plus de
poids sur la question de la vie privée
vous savez ici au canada c'est quelque
chose qui est important pour tout le
monde il ya des ans il ya beaucoup
d'enjeux de compromis entre la
protection de la vie privée et la
protection de la santé de la sécurité de
tout le monde
il faut que collectivement on fasse les
choix qui nous conviennent monsieur
bendjo pour terminer alors il ya
vraiment une solidarité là dans la
communauté scientifique
est-ce que vous tout le monde travaille
ensemble finalement là tout le monde se
mobilise et oui c'est incroyable en fait
toutes les barrières qui existait
auparavant les gens qui veulent
travailler pour avoir leur nom sur un
article ou gagner plus d'argent dans les
compagnies qui font les choses en secret
toutes ces barrières semblent
disparaître et tout le monde
l'abord de façon à atteindre l'objectif
de sauver des vies le plus vite possible
c'est vraiment extraordinaire et
j'aimerais que cet esprit qu'on voit se
développer naturellement on en regarde
quelque chose après cette crise très
bien et juste très rapidement quand
est-ce qu'on pourrait voir cette
application voir le jour je peux pas
vous donner une date mais on travaille
très fort pour essayer de déployer c'est
le plus vite possible parce que le plus
tôt on va mettre ça dans les téléphones
ça pourrait peut-être aussi tôt que la
semaine prochaine mais bon ça c'est est
optimiste dans le mois qui vient le plus
tôt on peut enregistrer ses contacts
on va pouvoir avoir un effet sur la
propagation du virus
merci infiniment monsieur peinture un
peu plaisir